well she's probably
send me the link i'll do the christina
bob thing because i think it is
significant we've seen yesterday
see if i can find it here we seen
yesterday uh where there was a report
that christina bob may have had
something to do
with
there we go seizing voting machines
she was writing orders
um if you guys don't know who christina
bob is they keep okay i'm gonna do the
christina bob thing here
christina bob let's make this bigger
there we go because i think this is
actually really significant news
um
and the reason why is because this is
part of the seditious conspiracy
this is the part of the conspiracy to
overturn the our vote
um spiro agnew
spear agnos ghost reported this breaking
metadata on the earliest known draft
copy of trump's executive order to seize
voting machines says the document
creator
and and here spiro agnew says onn
reporter which she is now currently an
onn reporter but she hasn't always been
is christina bob
well known as an off the charts trump
sycophant who was at the willard hotel
war room on the fifth and the sixth
um as uh kaelin here you go
kalyn points out here she likes to eat
cookies in the willard hotel room while
engaging in filthy [ __ ] seditious
conspiracy to overthrow the will of the
people in a freedom free and fair
election [ __ ] her
and here she is
let's zoom this in there she is
christina bob
now a lot of people think she's an oan
reporter which she is now but she hasn't
always been
she's not always been a [ __ ] oan
reporter
she was also involved in the fraud it
the the arizona [ __ ] with cyber
ninjas trying to overthrow an election
there
and the word is overthrow not overturned
they're trying to overthrow our
government that's what they're
continuing to do all around the country
the good news is is we have a lot of
democratic lawyers that are standing in
their [ __ ] way
and continue to stand in our way now if
you look here in this picture who is
this guy who's this guy john eastman
where do we know that [ __ ] from
well we know john eastman from the
powerpoint and the memo of how to commit
a cheeto dust kangaroo coup and we are
getting more and more clear
on what the what this uh alternative
slate the fraud slate of electors were
going to do and then we see [ __ ]
grandpa poopy or grandpa party mcshardy
excuse me i get them mixed up a few
times you know when you're connected at
the mouth and then and the you know what
you know it's hard to not confuse these
two
rudy giuliani sitting here at the table
you know going you know it looks like
he's trying to figure out how to work
his [ __ ] cell phone here
and christina bob
is eating [ __ ] cookies
like it's nothing you know it's just
another day of overthrowing the united
states government no big [ __ ] deal
now what you don't know about christina
bob and what a lot of people don't know
about christina bob is christina bob
was a government official for the
department of homeland security
are you listening
she's a former military officer
she's no she's not just some [ __ ]
dumb reporter for oann she's not
she knows what the [ __ ] she's doing
she's also a [ __ ] lawyer
and a [ __ ] traitor to her country
because she's not taking just one oath
when she was with with the military
she's taken another oath when she was
when she was sworn in at the department
of homeland security and she took
another [ __ ] oath when she became a
goddamn lawyer and entered the bar
and here she is eating cookies
overturning the constitution of the
united states wiping her [ __ ] ass
with it
planning to
maybe flush it down the [ __ ] toilet
they like to flush things down the
documents down the [ __ ] toilet
apparently
but christina bob is not just some
[ __ ] reporter with oann
christina bob didn't go to oann until
the 2020 election
until about june i think it was i don't
know the exact date but it's somewhere
june or july in 2020 is when she went
over to oann to spread propaganda before
that she was with let me say it again
the department of homeland security
did you hear department of homeland
security
a former military officer a lawyer
a licensed lawyer
she's significant in this plot 100 toe
she's significant and if you don't think
her role at oan is significant too it is
that's where the propaganda came from
that's how they spread the big lie that
was the [ __ ] plan the whole goddamn
time is if he lost they would try to
[ __ ] spread propaganda to make the
country just make him president
enters john eastman and grandpa farty
mcshardy rudy giuliani
you can call this a war room if you want
at the willard hotel
but if this is a war room this is the
cheeto confederacy
trying to overturn our vote
they were trying to steal our election
you know the stop the steal [ __ ] they
were stealing it it's always projection
with these [ __ ]
always
so don't get twisted up about who
christina bob is
she's not just some dumb oan reporter
that doesn't know what she's doing and
just takes orders
she's strategically placed at oan for a
[ __ ] reason when she was placed there
for the reason that she was replaced
she was with oan in
right here eating cookies
yup that's right she was with
she's just a lowly old reporter in the
war room at the willard hotel trying to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states
give me a [ __ ] break
and she needs to get paid more attention
to and quick
because my guess is she knows a lot of
[ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ]
about this conspiracy to overthrow the
constitution of the united states
and i'm sure i'm sure the department of
justice is looking into it
because we see
that they know that the memo that was
written
to unplug machines or seize the machine
so that way they could [ __ ] overthrow
the government
that way no one could question the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
the orange mussolini jesus himself
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
all right
we'll come back to christina bob i'm
sure in the future
in the future we will come back to
christina bob
let's go to the tree tweets and the
trendy trends here now of course you
know
maggie haberman's story she's number 10.
maggie writes an exclusive here
of trump communicating with kim jong-un
apparently these two
bros are still having a bromance
they still love each other well you know
i i wouldn't be opposed to him going on
his first date or i guess it would be a
second date
with kim jong-un in north korea would
you
i mean i'm all for it hell i'd pay for
the ticket
let's do that